la cloche ne sonne pas si on l'a vu
biron pourtant les élèves se rendent
assidûment en classe 2 fois par jour
ole morin les des zones y est on allé
girard david morin est enseignant dans
une école secondaire de trois rivières
il a dû se résigner à enseigner
virtuellement ses élèves
mais le traditionnel cours magistral lui
manquait il en 5 donc parallèlement dans
ce garage
prêté par des voisins dans lequel il a
aménagé une véritable classe pour les
enfants deux services étaient pas des
passions très important on retrouve
derrière son pupitre improvisé sept
élèves de tous les niveaux de la
troisième année du primaire jusqu'à la
première année du secondaire obtenions
cet après midi nous assistons aux cours
d'anglais poésie prévoyez pour lui quand
on a appris que les jeunes devaient soit
retournée à l'école soit donc faire
l'école à la maison on est un but à lens
on voulait pas vraiment les retourner à
l'école mais en même temps on n'est pas
totale non plus à enseigner donc moi je
me suis enfin je suis bon je vais ça
manque que je vais enseigner au début je
faisais proches au début du confinement
donc le poil là et a allumé le matin
vraiment comme un école de l'ahl comme
dans l'temps des filles de caleb une
école de rang aux décors bien moderne et
même si l'atmosphère est détendue c'est
du sérieux
les enfants travaillent à partir de leur
matériel scolaire et monsieur david suit
le plan fourni par leurs enseignants ce
que je crois qu'il faut juste pour la
fin ce qui effacerait macro progresser
au 5 milliards prélevés près l'an
prochain c'est le fonds est en
communication avec elle sortait
enseignants lucky qui ont su en fait que
je faisais ce procédé de me demander
comment comment vont leurs élèves j'ai
aucun doute au fait qu'ils vont être
payés puis même vous irez
ils vont être peut-être même heure sur
terre en droit en avance pour les
parents l'école du garage a permis de
chasse et bien des soucis moi tac père h
au säntis il enseigne à mon enfant qui
t'a sixième année parce que c'est très
loin en arrière fait que le d'avoir une
aide comme so so so gêne pour les
enfants c'est une source de motivation
c'est toute la gamme de riz qui viennent
dans le garage s'est fait parce que le
monsieur la ville de bourges histoire se
on apprend beaucoup de choses
des fois les frères et sarina est-ce que
c'est plus fun que l'école ben faudrait
pas de l'épreuve en temps selon oui il
faut dire que monsieur david a bien des
trucs pour les captiver juste une sortie
en vélo au village la journée d'école se
termine donc au casse-croûte chez lui
avec des élèves et un enseignant combler
si la motivation et la réussite vont de
pair l'école du garage pourra
certainement ajouter quelques étoiles à
son cahier ici valérie gamache radio
canada c'est étienne des grès